de longues avenues totalement déserte
des rangées de magasins fermés new york
retient son souffle
épicentre de la crise aux etats unis les
hôpitaux de manhattan sont pris d'assaut
les médecins et infirmières déborder
commencent à s'inquiéter pour leur
propre santé
habib ben ali est en fait nous sommes
terrifiés tout le monde est terrifié à
l'idée d'être infecté dix sept
infirmières les dents mais comme sa
carrière et le pire est encore à venir
car le pic de contagion ne sera pas
atteint avant trois semaines
d'ici là le gouverneur de new york
continue de faire des pieds et des mains
pour obtenir l'équipement nécessaire
comme des respirateurs mais enzo comme
on voit aussi des raisons d'espérer
because i am in such as tu as tu eu
d'incident majeur
maybe work les mesures de distanciation
sociale semble fonctionner dit il
le nombre de cas nécessitant une
hospitalisation augmente toujours mais
moins vite que prévu ce qui dans les
circonstances est presque trop beau pour
être vrai d'argent monstre gold to be 3
et pour permettre aux new yorkais de
sortir prendre l'air sans être trop
nombreux sur les trottoirs et dans les
parcs
le gouverneur fermera des rues à la
circulation accessible uniquement pour
les piétons au sommaire des mesures
bienvenues pour des millions de citoyens
enfermés chez eux depuis des semaines et
qui font preuve défini précaution à
chaque sortie comme preizerdaul on se
tient à distance les uns des autres dit
elle
on essaie désespérément pas tomber
malade louise shine tu as forêt noire
et si les autorités continuent d'espérer
une embellie new york se prépare au pire
une série de camions réfrigérés viennent
d'être stationné derrière cet hôpital de
manhattan
une morgue improvisée ici jean françois
bélanger radio-canada washington